hätte könnte ich habe heute ein special
guest an meiner seite leute eine runde
applaus für meine schwester
das nicht bekommen also sind am start
wir haben den eltern statt mit dabei
die kameras halten mit denen geschenkt
also wir sind bereit nicht hatte mir
nutzen wir die gelegenheit um einfach
mal gemeinsam eine youtubes zu nehmen
die du für immer geschaut hast
wolbeckerin es ist schon deutschland
verdrängt haben uns ein geiles
wasserbombe auf hamilton macdonald um
drei uhr nachts
das ist das maskottchen von mcdonald's
nein dieser clown das ist konnte 2020
einfach wasserbomben noch auf macs
moskau zu werfen deswegen geht es wieder
um das ist so krank das geht auch immer
weiter dieses trinkt ja aber du du du
hast früher mal ein fan von whatsapp
video zeiten das geschaut und es wurde
trotz schatzkammer tabuzone
aber hast du das auch noch geschaut und
13 ist so über dem durchschnittsalter
man ja wir müssen erst wieder schafft
[Gelächter]
drei stunden doku machen über komplexe
drei uhr nachts bewegung
dafür schauen wir dieses video hier weil
dieses video wird eine wasserbombe auch
eine eine fiktive werbefigur geworfen
ich konnte ich konnte nicht wissen weil
nicht alle
allerdings wird das ist das ist das
problem glaube die leute lesen also die
groß geschriebene worte wasserbomben 3
uhr haus maske ihn auf seine nummer
nicht mehr zuschauen wie tobias aber
unterblieben video ja wo ich diese
puppen aufgeschnitten habe und dieser
verdammte clown hinterher runter
geschrieben hat ist ihr hinterher
gerannt dass der bescheid sagen dass die
einspieler menschen jedoch wieder geht
das ist so krank also die allermeisten
leute wie glücklich so hardcore so auf
lsd sind oder so haben nicht solche
vorstellung dass das wasserbomben auf
ein werbe was kostet von irgendwas
rückkehr habe ich angst dass ist davon
so elfjährigen danach angegriffen
irgendwelche kleinen disclaimer ich
finde sie sehr nette person und ich
würde auf jeden fall mit dem ich mir
okay ihr habt euch so viel mühe gegeben
jetzt versucht mir wirklich zu helfen
der regen schuld ich euch das jetzt also
das ist das nämlich die sache weil die
ihre zuschauer haben auch schon so ein
fast ein wissenschaftliches interesse
daran zu erfahren was jetzt mit ronald
mcdonald s sie wollen hat auch bescheid
wissen so führen eine
wissenschaftseinrichtung in deutschland
das robert koch institut und alle
möglichen haben sich haben bei ihr nach
der freiheit besser gekocht
die deutschen haben ein recht das okay
und ich mache das einfach mal ich hoffe
aber nicht das werde aber auf jeden fall
braucht ist halt so korrekt von ihr dass
sie was macht das schon sehen das ist
sogar an korrekt alter dass die
allermeisten wird es nicht machen die
allermeisten würden sich nicht
es ist nicht trauen in diese gefahr zu
begeben heißt und ich würde dich
wirklich nicht drin ich habe ein paar
einfachen ja ich habe doch nicht ganz
aufgeholt weil die puppe manche hatte
aber ich konnte nicht auszumalen und
schreibt gewinne
wir werden uns jedenfalls um punkt 3 uhr
gleich wieder sehen bleibt gerne daumen
nach oben da wenn ihr mir gesellschaft
leisten würde so im nachschuss
jetzt mach mal irgendein zauberspruch
was weithin wird der zauberspruch ich
dachte ich sag mal so dass so ein
bisschen licht ins dunkel reinkommt du
musst nur 30 klar die mir gefällt's
ableiten würden dann habt ihr den daumen
nach oben da und als ich das wirklich
mal daumen warum jetzt da schreibt bitte
in die kommentare
ich will auf dem kanal selbst blockiert
die werke sind dafür nicht ich bin
selbst markiert ich kann mir keine
kommentare hier habe ich auch in zehn
jahren ja klar wir sehen uns gleich das
mittelalter hat diese schüsse so wenn
man auf sondern schießt was die ganzen
ministeriumsmitarbeiter und so ist ja
genauso diese normalen schüssel so
würden diese geschenke gut jetzt mal
schnell decke hier echt kannst
das wäre krank und das verstanden hast
dich kann ich wirklich ich gehe da kommt
auch nichts mehr ich kann mir jetzt auch
30 mal an da kommt nichts mehr
jk der checker super hatte xperia muss
viele leute alle kommentare die mission
gehört also ganz ehrlich nicht in der
wirklichkeit existierende werbefiguren
haben auch menschenrechte oder also die
man kann jetzt einfach wasserbomben auf
die werfen sie beleidigen 1000% niemand
vielleicht zwei prozent schaut das und
denkt sich dass es nicht echt 98 prozent
sehen denken ist
sie schreiben ja auch so 'oh mein gott
du hast das übersehen den hinweis und so
dass ein bisschen vater sei aber klar
dass ich schau mir die videos ja weil
die angst haben selbst gedreht hast du
also die personen beauftragt diese mit
ihrer schreibt so meinst du dir echt
jetzt natürlich dass das so funktioniert
und für die galas ohne selbst texte auf
gar keinen fall 1000% wenn ich lüge soll
ich jetzt die hand abfallen sie hat
einen freund oder freundin von sich
beauftragt hat den hat nun mit einer
neuen nummer so ein gespeichert oder den
ganzen keller immer gelöscht und hat es
dann so
nach dem vater gesagt ja schreiben wir
dass uns das 1000
hallo
was wollt dann müsst ihr müsst jetzt
erstmal ernstes wörtchen reden ja du
klein ist keine beleidigung
es ist wirklich so dass keine bleibt
aber wahre mutter geht auch zu landen
sie muss aber auch nicht direkt auf
beruf gehen das geht überhaupt nicht das
geht nicht also eher bedroht sie und sie
wissen jetzt dass musik einfach hier so
wasserbomben die er versorgt
ganz ehrlich wer denkt sich das wie
kommt man auf so was nervt verteidigen
so jetzt wird man ganz ehrlich an dem
punkt ganz ehrlich am helllichten tag
film ist ein stück sie muss den leuten
sagen leute ist es so dunkel und halle
ist so ok ja ja okay es ist glaube ich
glaube weil ich hier alleine mit einer
taschenlampe und ich habe noch eine
tasche mit mit dem wasserbomben rumlaufe
das wird sein
der städtische bestimmt nicht dass sie
mitten in der nacht mit ihrer kamera
redet das kann es nicht sagt es kann es
kann sein das liegt an den wasserbomben
die jackentasche waren sie zieht er
weiter sich so ein bobbycar so ein
bollerwagen mit mit so einem afghanen
zum riesige kreuz eine posse zur abwehr
komplett
geil zustand
[Musik]
der mann fällt einfach hin und dieses
als wenn es um bud spencer terence hilfe
im einfach so
die sägeblätter dafür nicht wirklich
beleidigt von sie muss schauen dass ich
mich wirklich persönlich beleidigt
worden dass ich dieses video angeschaut
habe und mir vielleicht denken könnte
die person die das video erstellt hat
denkt dass ich es ernst nehme und das
glaube da ist das ist zu viel für mich
daher kann sie zumindest die wasser
was sind das schon wieder für theorie
kommt
bisher hat sich die addierten die moskau
abgezogen jetzt kommt wieder ein nachts
videos über den wünschen damit
vielleicht will ja gar nicht dass das
passte zu urheberrecht hat sie darüber
nachgedacht
okay leute tabelle gesagt dass für diese
abmoderation gangster machen wir haben
auf jeden fall wieder einiges größer der
wm gute jobs in korrektem spaß gehabt
ihr kriegt ihr team einfach ich
vorgeschlagen wie oben könnte manchen
abonnieren wir sind an der stelle heraus
macht's gut